just over a week after the death of  beloved dancer Stephen twitch boss his  wife Allison took to her Instagram for  the first time Allison posted a selfie  with her late husband with the caption  reading my one and only oh how my heart  aches we miss you so much  I could spend the rest of my life with  you  out the couple's last post together was  just a couple days before the tragedy  and showed them dancing to Alicia Keys  December back to June the two had also  celebrated their ninth wedding  anniversary on December 11th thousands  of comments and photos have flooded in  since the passing of twitch including a  heartbreaking post from his mother a  screenshot of a video call with her son  with a note saying if only I could  FaceTime heaven  Allison announced the death of Twitch in  a statement to people last week stating  Stephen lit up every room he stepped  into he was the backbone of our family  the best husband father and inspiration  to his fans